nous accueillons notre invité du samedi
20 heures ce soir shérif de levon soir
chéri je l'aimais des enfants d'outreau
et vous publié au cherche midi un livre
témoignage intitulé je suis debout alors
je tiens à préciser qu'une partie de
votre livre contredit la vérité
juridique établi lors du procès et
odieux de la justice ce que vous
racontez relève de la mythomanie
voilà
[Musique]
chérif de les re bonsoir donc mineur à
l'époque des deux procès d'outreau les
enfants ne l'est pas eu le droit de
témoigner dans les médias c'est exact
mais aujourd'hui vous allez 21 ans et
vous témoigner aujourd'hui je peux
parler alors je rappelle à nouveau que
votre témoignage remet en cause une
décision de justice et qui est donc à
prendre comme tel aux yeux de la loi
vous êtes le fils de myriam badaoui et
de thierry de l'est mais ce dernier
n'est pas votre père biologique votre
père biologique votre mère l'a laissé en
algérie quand elle est venue s'installer
en france
arrivée en france elle rencontre et
épouse thierry de l'est qui vous
reconnaît comme son fils c'est exact
alors dès les premiers mois les
relations avec thierry de l'est sont
très violentes par exemple vous n'avez
pas le droit de dire papa
pas du tout et quand vous lui dites papa
il s'énerve complètement
donc j'ai pas le droit de lui dire papa
j'ai parole de regarder dans les yeux
et je peux pas être dans son chemin
corps voilà et sinon il vous met des
claques et des coups de ceinture ça a
commencé comme ça oui
alors à table vous devez manger loin de
lui complètement vous devez pas vous
adresser à lui même si je disais bon
appétit s'était il se levait et puis
voilà c'est
il commencé à m'insulter à me dire que
j'étais pas que j'étais pas la même
chose que j'ai
j'étais pas le même que lui voilà alors
tout ça est dû au racisme tout
simplement ils vous traitent
régulièrement de sales [ __ ]
oui on a beaucoup beaucoup insulté en
disant que
je ne suis pas de sa race qu'on n'a pas
la même couleur de peau une fois au sima
une mamie dans les toilettes pour
montrer excusez moi pour excuser moi
pour le terme sa merde en me disant que
voici pour moi tu es une merde
voilà
alors ce racisme pouces 2 les avons
rebaptisées vous appelez chérif et lui
ne veut vous appelez que kevin parce que
chérif faisait musulmans et musulmans
n'étaient pas admis à la maison ouais
alors vous dites j'ai été maltraité mais
je ne m'en rendais pas compte c'était
mon quotidien c'était normal c'est
effectivement à l'époque vous n'avez pas
d'autre exemple vous pensez que c'est
comme ça qu'on traite les enfants
c'était pour moi c'était la vie ouais
c'était comme ça way we de ma seule
référence paternelle n'apprenez la haine
en fait exactement il disait que pour si
je voulais deux comme lui il fallait
subir tout ça pour projet soit commuée
ouais pour être admis et accès après
accepté que je serai son fisc donc
thierry delesvaux bas de manière
rituelle
et vous connaissez rien d'autre donc
vous prenez l'habitude de vous
déshabiller d'offrir votre dos au cou
c'était c'était si je ressentais qu'il
arrive et que son regard
ça tirait vers moi
automatiquement c'est un réflexe il
faisant lever j'ai enlevé mon maillot et
voilà qu'en jeu coûte s'est ravisé voilà
alors un jour vous allez même jusqu'à
vous réveiller à l'hôpital après
plusieurs jours de coma tellement et
vous avez frappé mais à ce moment là
pourquoi cette situation n'est pas
signalée aux services sociaux
c'est une question peut-être qu'on
devrait leur poser aussi
mais mon médecin parce que plusieurs
fois j'ai été à l'hôpital
où j'ai fait des signes je pouvais pas
parler mais j'explique que j'expliquais
que
j'ai essayé de parler ont directement
mon beau père ou ma mère disait que
j'étais tombé où j'étais j'ai eu un
petit problème avec des avec d autres
enfants ouais vous avez quel âge à
l'époque j'avais 4 5 ans
alors vous prenez conscience de cette
situation à la naissance de votre demi
frère donc dimitri qui lui le fils
évidemment de myriam et de et de données
vous avez sept ans à noël dimitri reçoit
un super beau camion de pompiers et de
l'est vous dis tu aimes ce cadeau est
bien il n'est pas à toi il est à mon
fils et tu toucheras pas juste pendant
donc après le réveillon donc après le
repas de minuit
je suis rentré dans la chambre dimitri
et il a sauvé il a joué avec son son
camion de pompier et je me suis permis
de de prendre ce camion parce que lui
innocent comme il est et il m'a dit de
jouer avec lui
j'ai joué avec lui puis l'arrivée dans
la chambre et
il m'a dit qu'est ce que tu fais c'est
pas à toi c'est à mon fils donc mon
réflexe est arrivé j'ai pu j'ai enlevé
mon maillot complètement et puis pendant
30 minutes je me suis pris des coups de
ceinture des coudes et
puis après j'en passe et j'en passe quoi
alors vous prenez conscience également
de votre situation quand vous vous
retrouvez des fois dans des familles
d'accueil puisque votre mère besoin
d'eux dans les familles d'accueil alors
là on vous laisse jouer avec les enfants
évidemment et au début vous êtes inquiet
vous dit si je joue avec eux ça va me
falloir des coups de ceinture quand
l'arrivée dans la pièce mon réflexe est
arrivé j'ai enlevé mon maillot à me dis
qu'est-ce que la fdj mais tu dois me
taper tu m'as tu dois
tu dois tu dois faire qu'est ce que tu
dois faire quoi en quelque sorte ouais
et
et je crois que c'est au moment là
aujourd'hui comme j'ai grandi qu'elle a
compris
qu'ils se passait quelque chose à la
tête faire un test un jour tous les
matins on va chercher le pain on va on
va au marché a lâché des bonbons à son
fils à la même quantité que moi
et à me le donne je refuse qu'on m'a dit
non je peux pas c'est pas c'est pas pour
moi c'est pourtant fiche je sais
qu'après tu vas mettre la scène sur des
qu'on va arriver à la maison je crois
que c'est ça a commencé
ça commençait là vous vous dites
ma situation mais pas normal voilà et
puis à ce fameux noël 1996 vous avez un
cadeau et votre cadeau s'ils arrivent
c'est une cassette porno alors je
regarde le cadeau est en fait donc je
lui dit qu'est ce que c'est parce que
pour j'étais jeune donc je ne savais pas
mais qu'est ce que c'était complètement
je savais pas du tout et il m'a dit que
si tu veux on peut le regarder
et je lui dis j en fais je lui dis non
complète j'ai dit non ça me plaît pas
ouais et une audition mal regardé mes
posts sur la chaise il ma tâche et on a
regardé cette cette cassette ensemble et
à la fin de la cassette de l'est vous
dis maintenant on va faire la même chose
exactement c'est le premier viol
le lendemain vous êtes comment à légumes
à légumes et
je peux plus bouger je peux plus
je peux même plus parler je peux plus le
voilà alors après sur la suite des
événements votre version contredit la
vérité juridique vous affirmez avoir été
violée par sept personnes en plus de vos
parents sept personnes qui sont
aujourd'hui en liberté
je n'ai pas dit j'ai pas dit ça parce
que la loi ne permet pas d'expliquer
cette chose mais après chacun a le droit
à la parole chacun a le droit de
s'exprimer
chacun à le droit de juger comme il le
sent et c'était le but du livre c'était
je ne pouvais pas prendre un risque de
dire des noms pour encore une fois le ce
soit la justice ou la politique qui
m'interdit encore de m'exprimer
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui je crois que
on sue est le plus grand c'est qu'on
respecte ses enfants et qu'on donne la
parole et qu'on les écoute donc savait
pas dire non plus de les croire mais
aussi qu'on les écoute et qu'aussi qu'on
essaye de les comprendre que ce soit
dans les jus des enfants que ça soit
dans les services sociaux et raciaux
alors quand vous apprenez l'acquittement
de pratiquement tous les inculpés du
procès d'outreau là vous casser tout
autour de vous parce que vous devenez le
petit mythomane qui a fait condamner des
innocents une certaine façon ça vous
rend fou ça et puis j'avais un j'avais
un remords sur moi même parce que j'ai
pas réussi à parler parce qu'on en a
empêchés
on m'a insulté dès que je suis arrivé
j'étais pas bien du tout j'avais pas des
psychologique à l'époque tu très
étonnant derrière mais bon donc j'ai pas
pu mais que je n'ai pas pu m'exprimer
donc c'était de ma faute ouais voilà
parle avouent sombrer dans la
délinquance la drogue fait de la prison
vous passez une très très très mauvaise
période avec langil de [ __ ] en l'air
enfin vraiment une période terrible et
c'est en afrique que vous ce taux près
cette autodestruction pendant trois mois
vous apprenez à
nourrir des animaux et ça ça vous
réconcilie avec la vie d'une certaine
façon voilà c'est ça
l'afrique on va dire ces nouvelles
naissances pour moi
rencontrer l'amour l'amour aussi ouais
vous de faire votre vie en afrique
maintenant
je l'espère ouais vous encore très
perturbé quand même hein vous dit quand
je fais l'amour avec ma partenaire
j'ai des flashs joie le visage de ma
mère je ne je n'ai jamais réussi à faire
avoir des rapports sexuels complets avec
une femme alors grâce à facebook vous
avez retrouvé votre père biologique et
vous allez partir le voir en algérie
dans quelques semaines je vais voir mon
vrai père ma famille jésuite maintenant
j'ai j'ai trois soeurs j'ai un frère qui
est plus jeune que moi aussi qui
s'appelle shérif ouais
mon père m'a expliqué parce qu'il parle
pas beaucoup français mais qui m'a
expliqué c'était un hommage pour moi
c'était un genre dommage parce que pour
lui si la désespérée en complètement il
m'a recherché pendant plus de dix ans
et donc il a appelé mon petit frère
chérif et j'ai encore ma grand mère j'ai
encore une famille qui en algérie que
pour moi j'en avais plus du tout bien
sûr donc
est-ce que vous avez encore des contacts
avec votre mère myriam badaoui ou non
j'ai voulu la voir en prison il n'ya pas
rester récemment mais j'ai une lettre
où ou hadji carrément elle a le culot de
me dire 'est-ce que tu pourras me donner
la chance de prendre dans mes bras ou
ou de m'embrasser en fait vous avez
envie de la revoir pas du tout pas du
tout donc je voulais la voir c'était
c'était juste un moyen pour essayer de
rechercher mon père ou essayer de
de voir comment il s'appelle deux mois
juste pour retrouver votre père
biologique en fait et aujourd'hui vous
espérez quoi est ce que vous espérez par
exemple que après les deux procès il ya
un troisième procès outreau de façon à
punir les gens dont vous dites que vous
sincèrement aujourd'hui c'est plus mon
problème
or ça je vais être clair c'est que pour
moi c'est fini je veux je veux en finir
parce que moi j'ai ma vie je vois mon
futur je veux voir mon présent et je
veux plus me mettre dans la tête ou trop
trop ou trop ouais ça soit pour les
jours où les journalistes et où il faut
qu'on arrête avec ça il faut tourner la
page faut arrêter de se nourrir avec
cette affaire je crois que maintenant il
est il est temps de tourner cette page
et de voir le présent et le futur ce
livre c'est une façon de dire ce qu'on
vous a pas laissé dire à l'époque vous
étiez mineurs et puis ensuite c'est fini
c'est fini aussi c'était reprends ma
dignité qu'aujourd'hui je la reprends
parce que maintenant tout le monde c'est
une deuxième vérité d'outreau ouais
c'était un peu mon objectif aussi que
d'autres victimes parlent aujourd'hui on
la force de parler aussi les anciennes
victimes se disent
qu'on peut encore ont pas encore être
debout mais qui est le titre du livre on
va encore être debout après tout ça est
et puis dire fin ou trop ouais
tous les cas merci de votre témoignage
et puis on vous souhaite effectivement
de vivre une nouvelle vie en afrique
avec des gens
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux